pensez que le meilleur joueur du monde
ne font jamais de grosses gaffes dans
leur partie en classique et bien
détrompez-vous vous allez voir qu'ils
font parfois bien pire que nous on va
voir ensemble le top 3 des pires gaffes
de l'histoire des échecs par les
meilleurs joueurs du monde on commence
par look du champion de France Etienne
Bacro qui dans cette position avec les
Blancs contre le grand maître inarkief
nous a délecté d'un dameset échecrois
offrant tout simplement sa dame à son
adversaire avec un abandon immédiat
ensuite on a une légende du jeu tigram
Petrossian confronte une autre légende
Brunstein les Noirs ont joué cavalier F5
pour attaquer la dame en D6 et ici au
calme petrocyan a répondu par cavalier
G5 ah d'accord cavalier prend dames
abandon on parle toujours de partie
lente et la palme d'or revient à
Vladimir craminic l'ex champion du monde
contre l'ordinateur deep frites dans
cette position alors que les Blancs
menaces dames achète il a joué
tranquillement dame 3 pour proposer
l'échange des dames et c'est bien sûr
fait punir par damasheetmat